Piera facciamo un attimo il punto della
situazione perché ormai siamo agli
sgoccioli Eh allora di antipasto fare un
due tre fettine di vitellone No giusto
due perché tanto Eh siamo due gattine
poi un po' di agnolotti non troppi Eh
perché sennò ci rimangono sullo stomaco
e poi il brasato io non c'ho mica voglia
di cucinarlo e lui è lungo lungo la
procedimento No no dai allora ragazzi
Cosa volete mangiare a Natale
casoncellivan bergamasca va bene
esottina la milanese con l'ossobuco TAC
anguilla al cartoccio
classicone polenta concia da sentirsi
male Beh ovviamente pane tu ma non c'è
neanche bisogno di dirlo pronto
gastronomia Fumagalli Sì sono la Franca
Meneghini Sì Salve senta volevo
prenotare e il pranzo di Natale Sì se a
carta e penna Le dico subito i piatti
velina Allora 24 sera facciamo i
maccheroni in brodo così 25 poi facciamo
una mira alla genovese non mi dire che
volevi caso non c'è lì perché te li
mangia tutti i giorni Casoncelli In
totale sono 22 1941 pagate in anticipo
perché non ci vuole andare sotto Ascolta
Silvana Allora allora di antipasto
volevo fare dei crostini Asiago polenta
e radicchio poi risotto al radicchio
Polenta e baccalà immancabile e
ovviamente pandoro eh pandoro a volontà
Senti ma vorrei fare anche un po' de
mostarda eh Cosa dici tu già hai trovato
la roba mi pare poca Insomma
un po' di passatelli così ti accontenti
tutti mo' Certo la lasagna te la mangi
però dopo eh Facciamo anche un po' di
tagliatelle ma il culatello te lo mangi
prima eh Eh certo lo zampone con
lenticchie meglio farlo a capodanno Eh
scusa per prima cosa i crossini fegatini
poi cappelletti il bar dico che lei è
una salsiccia di maiale al finocchio che
viene cucinata alla brace dopo la
mezzanotte non prima dopo e di dolce ci
sono i cavallucci di ceneri il panforte
in Toscana tu a Natale a stomaco vuoto
Non ci resti farei tantissima pasta
ripiena possiamo fare i cappelletti con
Piccione o Cappone e Oppure possiamo
fare anche i maccheroncini Campofilone
la vigilia facciamo capitone baccalà e
fritto misto
25 invece abbacchio con le patate
pasta al forno e un classicone insalata
di puntarelle me ne sono tre cose
cucinano Nicola lei cime di rapa le
pittule eh È un minestra di scarola e
poi vediamo l'iPhone con lampascioni eh
È quello eh e le carte a mia madre anche
in testa Se continua così e niente
preparo il color Jones ma lo redus la
fragola Alza le bottarga e poi il
progetto col mirto
Eh e vabbè ma certamente anche lei
seadas Eh e ti pare che hanno le cucino
le se Ada sono le mie preferite cosa
cucino Ma giusto due cosette perché
comunque quest'anno non c'ho voglia di
cucinare te lo devo dire allora volevo
fare un po' di pane Cameo sa 4 kg di
sfincioni 5 timballi con gli anellini
tre taglie di frittata di pasta poca
poca pasta con le sarde circa 2 kg e
mezzo e poi di dolce cannolis vince la
ricotta e mi viene di Sant'Agata però ho
paura che non basti secondo te